اقتحمت قوه من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ليله مخيم شعفاط شمالي القدس المحتله
واعتقلت سيده فلسطينيه وسيرت قوات
الاحتلال دوريات راجله واليات وانتشرت في
عدد من الاحياء كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
بلده الخضر في مدينه بيت لحم واطراف مخيم
الدهيشه قال مراسل الجزيره ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت لله اطراف
مخيم بلاطه والمنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه
نابلس شماليه الضفه كان الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني قد افاد باصابه شاب فلسطيني
برصاص الاحتلال خلال عمليه اقتحام سابقه
اندلعت خلالها مواجهات بينها وبين الشبان
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيين وفي رام الله قالت مصادر طبيه
فلسطينيه ان طفلا استشيل برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الشرقيه المدينه كما اصيب شاب
فلسطيني برصاص قوات الاحتلال في بلده كفر
نعمه في غربي رام الله كانت قوات الاحتلال
قد اقتحمت برفقه دائره الاثار الاسرائيليه
منطقه سكا في غرب مدينه دوه وقريتي بدرس
وقيا في غرب رام الله من ناحيته قال نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني ان عدد من اعتقلهم
الاحتلال في الضفه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
تجاوز
الان ينضم الينا من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري ليطلع على اخر التطورات
في الضفه وايضا حديث الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عن انه انتهى من عملياته العسكريه في بعض
المواقع حل التفاصيل اضافيه
محمد نعم نشوان في اخر التفاصيل قوات
كبيره جدا من الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تقتحم في هذه الاثناء مخيم بلاطه والمناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه نابلس ولعل التركيز الاكثر
هو داخل مخيم بلاطه الحديث يدور عن اقتحام
عدد كبير من الاحياء داخل المخيم قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تطبق حصارها على هذه
الاحياء في هذه الاثناء شهد عشرات من
الجنود الاسرائيليون ينتشرون داخل مخيم
بلاطه وسمع اطلاق تبادل لاطلاق النار من
داخل المخيم وكذلك اصوات انفجارات متعدده
من داخل المخيم فيما ايضا اصطحبت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي معها الى مخيم بلاطه
جرافه عسكريه اسرائيليه هذه الجرافه عملت
على ازاله بعض الحواجز التي نصبها شبان
فلسطينيون في مداخل بعض الاحياء لا تزال
الاشتباكات مستمره في مخيم بلاطه في هذه
الاثناء الحديث يدور عن اقتحام اسرائيلي
كبير وواسع في المخيم وشهود يؤكدون ان
هناك تبادل اطلاق النار يدور في هذه
الاثناء داخل بعض الاحياء في قلب مخيم
بلاطه وكذلك شهدت اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه
في المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه نابلس هذا جاء
بعد اقتحام اسرائيلي سابق لمدينه نابلس
هذه الليله حيث اقتحمت قوات
اسرائيليه شارع رفيديا وسط المدينه وهناك
دارت رحى الاشتباكات بين القوات
الاسرائيليه والمواطنين الفلسطينيين
القوات الاسرائيليه في نابلس ردت على
الشبان الفلسطين ين باطلاق الرصاص الحي
وهو ما ادى الى اصابه احد الشبان بجراح
نقل على اثرها الى المستشفى وكذلك في
مدينه القدس المحتله اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيم شعفاط
وسيرت دوريات راجله في شوارع المخيم
واحيائه وهذه القوات ايضا حاولت محاصره
بعض البنايات وكذلك الاحياء واعتقلت سيده
فلسطينيه التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه مستمر
ن شوان وهو في هذه الاثناء في عده مدن
فلسطينيه وخاصه في جنوب وشمال الضفه
الغربيه حيث اقتحمت ايضا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه بيت لحم وشهدت الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في مركز المدينه
وخاصه بالقرب من كنيسه المهد كما اقتحمت
قوات اسرائيليه ايضا مخيم الدهيشه في
المدينه وبلده الخضر ويدور الحديث عن عدد
كبير من الاليات العسكر الاسرائيليه التي
تتوزع في منطقه بيت لحم وتقتحم بعض القرى
التي والتي ذكرنا عددا منها وكذلك دعني
اقول ان الى جانب الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه
اقتحم عدد كبير من المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين اليوم تجمعا لمواطنين
فلسطينيين في مسافر يطا في منطقه الخليل
اعتدوا على اشجار الزيتون وقلعوها وكسرو
وكذلك اقتحم مستوطنون عددا من منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين في الحقيقه واخبروه
وهددوهم فع
انهم سيقتلون او يتعرضون لاعتداءات في حلم
يغادروا مساكنهم ويهاجروا تلك الديار